just before we get started this video is
made possible by Nord VPN data security
and privacy concerns are something that
you hear about all the time hacks
breaches things of that nature but good
news you can protect yourself with a VPN
and that's where Nord VPN comes in I've
been sitting in a cafe yet like login to
the Y feeling like I'm just gonna check
mines in their banking don't do that you
got to use a VPN well let's say you were
a foreign person living somewhere with
restricted internet or maybe just geo
restrictions and you wanted to watch a
fun youtube video like this one meta
well Nord VPN will sort you out it's
also super fast so watching a video is a
breeze there's no lag if you have used
VPNs in the past as oh you know video
you say age is too low not with Nord VPN
it's incredibly speedy you can use it on
all your devices as well Android Chrome
Windows or Linux and you can use it on
six different devices with just one
account and unlike VPNs that are based
in the EU or the US nor VPN they're
based in Panama so they don't have to
keep any logs at all great for your
privacy indeed they are the only VPN to
get a perfect score from PC Mag Nord VPN
is offering our viewers 70% of a
three-year plan just go to Nord VPN
console politick or click the link in
the description below and let's get into
it
[Applause]
let me ask you a question which do you
prefer the country or the city okay so
I'm sure your answer is going to depend
on what sort of activity you have in
mind if we want to spend a few days away
from the hustle and bustle of the city
would probably choose the countryside
[Music]
but if instead we think about day to day
life undertaking her own business
projects or going on a night out the
answer is probably going to change
completely don't fool yourself we all
like cities and that's got consequences
for the first time ever in history more
than half the world's population lives
in cities
[Music]
cities have emerged as the nuclei in
which people completely unknown to each
other and of various origins coexist and
coordinate their lives to fulfill their
goals who hasn't felt amazed by the
hustle and bustle of London of New York
of Tokyo it's a huge mix of cultures
religions nationalities cities are made
up of very different people but many
have something in common and that's the
desire to grow as a society and it's
pretty amazing without thinking about it
or in many cases without even being
aware of it we contribute to the welfare
of a lot of people we don't even know
and they do the same in return by
providing a lot of services that we need
it is precisely for this reason folks
that cities have been consolidated as
the axis the nucleus the engine in the
freest and most prosperous human society
model that humanity has ever known
but does the growth of cities today pose
a threat to the rural world our cities
meeting the needs of their residents and
how is global urbanization affecting
people's lives well let's take a look
shall we from the countryside to the
city from the countryside to the city
I'm sure many of you have grandparents
or great-grandparents who were born and
lived in a village because the migration
from the countryside to the city has
been a relatively recent phenomenon you
all know this historically humans lived
scattered in small communities where
life was based on subsistence farming
and whatever products they were able to
produce if you were lucky you might have
your own plot of lands where you'd raise
a few animals and plant a few vegetables
which you later consume
as you can imagine life was very very
hot people spent their lives working
from childhood to try and get ahead
often with no chance of ever securing a
better life and what's more the risk of
external factors making life worst was
extremely high
for example drought or flood could lead
to a terrible famine that could end the
lives of thousands upon thousands of
people not to mention Wars invasion and
of course disease that's why among other
things mortality it was so high in the
past so would you like to go back to the
good old days probably not right I mean
don't get yourself in 99% of cases
things that were much worse in general
cities offer us a higher quality of life
and a range of opportunities
it all began with industrialization back
in the 18th and 19th centuries which
also led to a boom in trade and
technological innovations
[Music]
[Applause]
in that era cities began to grow
exponentially by attracting millions of
people from the countryside who wanted
to improve their living conditions and
that's the definition of urbanization
massive transfer of people from the
countryside to the city that has been
happening continuously for more than two
centuries it's a process that has
allowed many completely new economic
activities to flourish improving
everyone's lives since as recently as
the 1960s the world's urban population
is multiplied by 4 while the rural
population has grown very slowly and has
almost reached its tipping point it's
estimated the between 2025 and 2030 the
world's rural population will begin to
shrink for the first time in the history
of mankind so far it's decreased in
relative terms but now it will also
begin to do so in absolute terms
[Music]
basically we live in a world of cities
now how might this change affect us well
obviously in order to live we need goods
to be produced in the countryside's in
particular food and this leads us to a
big question that comes up every once in
a while and that's cannae world of
cities feed the planets growing
population does this urbanization
process threaten our food security now a
lot of people say yes but we're not so
sure so a question we need to ask
ourselves is are we producing food in
the same way we did 50 years ago the
short answer's no we're not nowadays we
don't need 10 20 or 30 farmers to plow a
couple of hectares of land john deere 80
to 85 our ore is just more than enough
[Music]
this has a name you probably heard
mechanization this is new technologies
being used which incidentally tend to be
developed in the cities and they've
brought tremendous improvements to the
rural environments improvements that's
of course translate into a better
quality of life and the countryside
mechanization has greatly reduced the
number of workers required in the fields
not only maintaining but even increasing
agricultural production
that's exactly why Malthusian theories
the theories that claim the world is
suffering from overpopulation that we
don't have the resources to feed
everyone fail over and over and over
again
however hold on a second folks because
as you might imagine this population
explosion creates many many challenges
in the cities especially in developing
countries the main one is urban poverty
caused among other things by the
scarcity of housing that occurs in
extreme cases of urban explosion we're
going to take a closer look at in a
minute but despite these challenges and
problems have you ever wondered what
exactly is the big attraction that
cities offer that leads so many people
to move to them well listen up
[Music]
city's cooperation hubs
why did industrialization emerge in
cities why are the head officers of
major companies always in the largest
cities well it's not only about having
access to better infrastructure such as
roads ports or airports but also about
having easy access to all of us that's
human resources companies need a lot of
different profiles different people to
be able to function have you ever
wondered how many people are involved in
the creation of just one everyday
product say for example a car you need
enter in his mechanics designers even
other Tanner's and artisans for the
vehicles interior details that's
precisely why the biggest cities where
more people of different profiles
coexist of the ideal place to find human
resources the more professionals and
different profiles there are the more
attractive the place is going to be
cities have become true hubs of human
cooperation where we fill the needs of
others and they in turn supply us with
what we lack
all this without even knowing us it's
rather incredible these hubs of
businesses entrepreneurship and
consumers have triggered economic growth
[Applause]
now at this point there's a question we
need to ask ourselves here on visual
politic and that's where is this
phenomenon happening most markedly do
you know
can you guess I'm sure it's not going to
surprise you because it's happening in
Asia but hold on a second because Africa
is already catching up and this is
hardly surprising since the beginning of
urbanization the income per capita for
the most urbanized Asian countries has
skyrocketed urbanization is directly
related to economic developments the
great amounts of knowledge goods and
services exchanges that take place in
cities were something unknown to mankind
until very recently they have something
of a modern miracle
Asian countries that have experienced
greater migrations from the country site
of the city have seen their citizens per
capita income skyrocket that's the case
in South Korea Thailand Japan and
Malaysia among others
check out this chart the greater the
concentration of inhabitants the higher
the country's per capita income and the
variation in just ten years between 2000
and 2010 leaves no room for doubt but
these aren't isolated cases this
phenomenon has extended throughout the
developed world Western Europe for
example was by far the first place to
experience urbanization doubling and
even tripling the rate of urbanization
found in the rest of the world in other
words to a large extent the old
continent success can be attributed to
its pioneering bet on cities in fact
with this data in hands the first thing
that may come to mind is how it is
surprising that it took so long for the
other regions to join this phenomenon
and yet achieve similar results so
quickly and it's not just an economic
issue not at all
science culture and political freedoms
have almost always originated in cities
[Music]
cooperation between human beings is
easier and simpler in these spaces
making it easier of a creativity
serendipity and influential political
movements to emerge and of course this
is no surprise in a village being
different or thinking differently can
make you an outcast in cities you become
one more part of an artistic
intellectual or political movement it's
really that simple now hold on just a
second I mean how can we accommodate
millions of rural people in cities
without having the necessary housing
infrastructure and services in India
well they know a bit about this
challenge
[Music]
India explosive organization
so we've already talked about this here
on visual politic India is starting to
become a manufacturing powerhouse it's
beginning to take its first steps
towards becoming China's competitor for
example Apple has already announced that
we'll stop manufacturing the new iPhone
in China to do it in India instead which
is pretty incredible actually Foxconn is
said close to trial output of newest
iPhones in India and of course
India's industrialization will require a
lot of workers people who are arriving
on mass from the countryside to the
cities
the urbanization phenomenon is happening
so rapidly that in India and in many
other cities of the developing world
guaranteeing access to basic services
such as electricity running water
education health and infrastructure is
posing gigantic problems as it requires
huge investment and this investment
poses quite a challenge in some
countries for example delegates around
700,000 new residents every single year
and already has more than 27 million
inhabitants in its metropolitan area its
growth is so astronomical by 2028 it
could become the largest mega city in
the world surpassing even Tokyo but hold
on just a second how can homes for
700,000 people be built in a single year
and what's more how can it be done year
after year after year in India
urbanization is happening very quickly
and this entails difficulties in
guaranteeing access to housing for all
the people arriving in the city due to
this is estimated that 24 percent of the
urban population lives in shanty towns
without even the most basic living
conditions basically in order to
accommodate all of Delhi's new
inhabitants you'd need to build between
700 and 900 million square meters of
accommodations every single year this
works outing something roughly the size
of Chicago being built every year so now
we have to ask is this even possible
it seems like a complicated challenge
and unfortunately many newcomers they're
forced to live in those shanty towns
which are better known as slums in Lao
boxy largest slum in Delhi more than
300,000 people live in a single square
kilometre it's really quite horrific
despy the Indian government's efforts to
build houses to relocate the poorest the
challenge is so huge that it's like
fighting against the clock to reduce
something that just doesn't stop growing
[Music]
so how is India going to deal with this
problem well we're going to talk about
this on a later video right here on
visual politic so I really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos also
don't forget to check out our friends at
reconsider media and our fantastic
sponsor for this episode naud VPN you
will find a link to them below
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]